From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So a while back, Brian Reed, who at the time was the senior producer of our show and he'd recently finished this great seven-episode podcast called S-Town, he was going around giving speeches every now and then about S-Town. And he was out giving a speech when a journalism student in Birmingham, England, approached him and told him a story, something that had been big news there. And there was still a mystery at the heart of it that nobody had ever solved.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。很久以前，布莱恩·里德当时是我们节目的高级制作人，他刚刚完成了名为《S-Town》的七集播客，那是一部非常出色的作品。在一次演讲活动中，一位来自英国伯明翰的在校新闻系学生走近他，讲述了一个在那边引起巨大轰动的事件。而那件事的核心至今仍有一个未解之谜。
And Brian decided to team up with this student. And, honestly, they have been like dogs with a bone running this down, through many twists and turns, and officials trying to avoid them or shut them down. The student, Hamza Syed, is now a former journalism student and somebody who is in all of our lives. He moved here to the United States to finish the story, which became much too big to fit into one or two episodes of our program.
布莱恩决定与这位学生联手调查。说实话，他们就像咬住骨头的猎犬一样穷追不舍，经历了许多曲折，甚至还要面对官员们的推诿和阻挠。这位学生哈姆扎·赛义德现在已经不再是新闻系学生，而是我们生活中的一部分。他搬到了美国来完成这篇报道，因为这个故事的体量远超我们节目一两集的篇幅。
So our colleagues at Serial took it over to turn into a podcast series. Sarah Koenig, the host of Serial, became their editor. The series rolled out this week. And it's spectacular, completely original. I'm very excited to play you the first installment of the show today, on our show, so you can hear what it's like. I defy you not to get caught up in the story the way that we all were. And so, with that, I'll hand things over to Hamza for part 1 of The Trojan Horse Affair.
于是，我们《Serial》的同事接手了它，将其制作成播客系列。该节目的主持人莎拉·凯尼格担任他们的编辑。这个系列在本周推出，非常震撼且完全原创。我非常兴奋今天能在我们的节目中播放第一集，让大家感受一下。我敢说，你们一定会像我们所有人一样被这个故事深深吸引。那么，现在就把时间交给哈姆扎，请听《特洛伊木马事件》第一部分。
This is my first story as a journalist. I hadn't planned for it to be my last story, but it probably will be, given what's happened in the years I've been working on this. It's about a letter that surfaced in my city and had huge consequences for Britain. This letter launched four government investigations, changed our national policy, and ended careers. It's hurt some of the country's most vulnerable children. A letter that many people who've seen it agree is ridiculous.
这是我作为记者的第一个故事。我没计划让它成为最后一个，但考虑到这几年我在调查中经历的一切，它很可能就是了。这是一个在我所在的城市浮出水面，并对英国产生巨大影响的信件的故事。这封信引发了四项政府调查，改变了我们的国家政策，也终结了许多人的职业生涯。它伤害了该国一些最脆弱的儿童。而这封信，许多见过的人都认为它是无稽之谈。
It's unsigned, undated.
它没有署名，没有日期。
It didn't look like a serious document, did it?
看起来不像是一份严肃的文件，对吧？
It just seemed comical. Like, what the hell is this?
看起来简直滑稽。就像在说，这到底是什么鬼东西？
I remember looking at it for some time, thinking, what on Earth is this?
我记得盯着它看了很久，心想，这到底是什么玩意儿？
The infamous letter, was it written on parchment, in blood?
那封臭名昭著的信，是用羊皮纸写的吗？还是用血写的？
So you're presenting me with a document that turned our lives upside down.
所以你拿给我看的文件，就是把我们的生活搅得天翻地覆的东西。
I first learned of the letter in 2014. I wasn't a journalist then. I was a doctor who'd quit medicine, living in Birmingham, England, making my breakfast at 1:00 PM, listening to the news, when I heard about the discovery of a secret communiqué between Muslim extremists. They were discussing a plot to infiltrate our city schools and run them on strict Islamic principles, potentially with the aim of radicalizing students.
我是2014年第一次听说这封信的。那时我还没做记者。我是一名辞职的医生，住在英国伯明翰。下午一点钟，我正准备做早饭，听着新闻，突然听到关于发现了一封穆斯林极端分子之间秘密通讯的消息。他们正在密谋渗透我们城市的学校，并以严格的伊斯兰原则来管理，目的是为了让学生激进化。
Someone had forwarded the letter anonymously to the local government, the Birmingham City Council, but it was missing the first and last page. So it was unknown exactly who wrote it or who they were sending it to. According to the intercepted pages, the plot had a code name, Operation Trojan Horse.
有人匿名将这封信转发给了当地政府，也就是伯明翰市议会，但信件丢失了第一页和最后一页。所以根本不知道是谁写的，也不知道是写给谁的。根据截获的页面显示，这个阴谋有一个代号：特洛伊木马行动。
I have to admit, when this story about Muslims in Birmingham first broke, as a Muslim in Birmingham, I was alarmed. It sounded possible. Kids across Britain, across Europe, were flying off to Syria to join this group called ISIS. And Birmingham has been home to quite a few terrorists. My neighbor was a terrorist, the guy who killed five people and then tried to run into Parliament with a knife. He did his planning in a flat above the Persian restaurant across the street from me.
我必须承认，当这个关于伯明翰穆斯林的故事首次曝光时，作为一名在伯明翰生活的穆斯林，我感到非常震惊。这听起来似乎很有可能。英国各地、欧洲各地的孩子们都在飞往叙利亚加入一个叫做ISIS的组织。而伯明翰一直是不少恐怖分子的家乡。我的邻居就是一个恐怖分子，那个杀害了五个人，然后试图拿着刀冲进议会的人。他就是在离我街对面波斯餐馆楼上的公寓里策划这一切的。
So I wasn't surprised, watching, as over the next several months Operation Trojan Horse snowballed into a huge national story.
所以，在随后的几个月里，看着“特洛伊木马行动”像滚雪球一样变成巨大的全国性新闻时，我并不感到惊讶。
A number of schools in Birmingham have been infiltrated by hard-line Muslims.
伯明翰的一些学校已经被强硬派穆斯林渗透了。
Radical Muslims--
激进穆斯林——
Headlines like "Islamist Plot," "Jihadist Plot."
头条新闻写着“伊斯兰阴谋”、“圣战阴谋”。
Alleging a conspiracy by--
声称存在一个阴谋，由——
And the government responded with full force. The prime minister got involved, convening his cabinet to discuss the threat. The national government sent in a bunch of investigators, including Scotland Yard's former head of counterterrorism, to look into two dozen schools in majority Muslim areas of Birmingham.
政府对此进行了全面回应。首相介入了，召集内阁讨论这一威胁。中央政府派出了大批调查人员，包括苏格兰场的前反恐主管，对伯明翰穆斯林占多数地区的两打学校进行了调查。
Like I say, it was all very frightening. Until a few months later, when the various investigators finally started reporting their findings. They'd found no plot called Operation Trojan Horse. They'd seen no signs that anyone had been radicalized and no evidence of violence or planned violence. They didn't bring any terror charges against anyone working at the schools they'd looked into.
正如我所说，这一切非常可怕。直到几个月后，各位调查人员终于开始报告他们的发现。他们没有发现所谓的“特洛伊木马行动”阴谋。他们没有看到任何人被激进化的迹象，也没有发现任何暴力或策划暴力的证据。他们没有对他们所调查的学校中的任何人提出任何恐怖主义指控。
But despite all of that, despite finding no plot, investigators still concluded that Muslims had influenced the schools in a dangerous way. Government officials snapped into action.
但尽管如此，尽管没有发现阴谋，调查人员仍然得出结论，认为穆斯林以危险的方式影响了学校。政府官员立即采取了行动。
Things that should not have happened in our schools were allowed to happen. Our children were exposed to things they should not have been exposed to.
本不该在学校发生的事情被允许发生了。我们的孩子接触到了他们本不该接触到的东西。
The fallout has been huge. Prime Minister David Cameron, as we said, is calling a special meeting of the--
后果极其严重。首相戴维·卡梅伦，正如我们所说的，正在召开特别会议——
Officials removed educators, revamped schools, and renamed them. They mandated all schools in the country start teaching what they termed "British values," to make kids less susceptible to extremist ideas. They beefed up Britain's counter-extremism laws by making public sector workers like teachers and doctors part of the state surveillance apparatus, to now inform on their co-workers and students and patients.
官员们撤换了教育工作者，重组了学校并重新命名。他们强制要求全国所有学校开始教授所谓的“英国价值观”，以降低孩子们对极端思想的敏感度。他们通过使教师和医生等公共部门工作人员成为国家监视机构的一部分，加强了英国的反极端主义法，让他们去举报同事、学生和病人。
Today, the prevailing narrative of the Trojan Horse affair is that a bunch of Muslims were up to no good. There is another version of the story though. That version of the Trojan Horse Affair is that nothing happened. That these bearded Brown educators were set up. And the nation fell for it. And it's always seemed to me that there's a simple way to figure out what really happened-- the letter.
今天，关于“特洛伊木马事件”的主流叙事是，一群穆斯林没干好事。不过，这个故事还有另一个版本。那个版本是：什么都没发生。这些留着胡子的棕色皮肤教育者是被陷害的。而全国人民都信了。对我来说，查明真相的方法很简单——就是那封信。
Even with all the government inquiries, no authority, none of the investigators ever figured out who wrote it. Remarkably, none of them even tried. And that, to me, seemed like a pretty glaring oversight. The reason the country was looking at these schools in suspicion, the reason they were investigating them at all, was because this dodgy letter showed up, portraying the people who worked there as nefarious plotters, claiming they were sneaking Islam into schools, like a Trojan Horse.
即便在政府进行了多次调查后，没有任何权威机构，没有任何调查员找出过写信的人。令人震惊的是，他们甚至根本没去尝试过。这对我来说是一个非常明显的疏忽。国家怀疑这些学校的原因，他们调查这些学校的原因，仅仅是因为这封可疑的信出现了，将那里工作的人描绘成邪恶的阴谋家，声称他们像特洛伊木马一样偷偷把伊斯兰教引入学校。
The letter is what put the idea in authorities' heads. So I didn't see how you could know what Operation Trojan Horse was or wasn't unless you got to the bottom of the Trojan Horse letter, who wrote it and why.
这封信是权威部门脑子里产生这个想法的根源。所以我认为，除非弄清那封特洛伊木马信的真相——到底是谁写的，为什么要写——否则你不可能知道“特洛伊木马行动”到底是什么。
A few years later, I decided to go to school for investigative journalism. But my professor wasn't completely sold on a story I wanted to report for my student project, Operation Trojan Horse. This was investigative journalism. He wanted me to unearth something new, not rake over some years-old story.
几年后，我决定去读调查新闻学。但我的教授对我想作为学生项目报道的这个故事——“特洛伊木马行动”——并不完全买账。这是调查新闻学。他希望我挖掘出新的东西，而不是翻炒一个多年前的故事。
As a doctor though, I'm familiar with the concept of a second opinion. So the night before my master's was set to start, I went looking for one.
不过作为医生，我熟悉“第二意见”这个概念。所以在我硕士课程开学的前一天晚上，我去找了另一个人咨询。
A doctor came to see me for a second opinion. One night in fall of 2017, I'm in a theater in Birmingham. After my podcast S-Town came out, I went around doing some Q&As. Afterwards, people will sometimes come backstage to chat.
一位医生来找我寻求第二意见。2017年秋天的一个晚上，我正在伯明翰的一家剧院。我的播客《S-Town》发布后，我四处做了一些问答交流。事后，人们有时会来后台聊天。
And so, this guy comes in, introduces himself as Hamza Syed. He said he was changing careers to become a reporter. He was beginning a master's program in investigative journalism the next day, actually. And he wanted some advice. He was speaking fast, like I might walk away at any moment.
然后，这个家伙进来了，介绍自己叫哈姆扎·赛义德。他说他正在转行做记者。其实第二天他就要开始修读调查新闻学的硕士课程了。他想咨询些建议。他说话语速很快，好像我随时会走开一样。
To be fair, I was told that I had 5 minutes with Brian Reed, after which I'd be escorted out of the building.
公平地说，有人告诉我我只有5分钟时间见布莱恩·里德，之后就会被带离大楼。
I did not know that. Anyway, Hamza ran through the Trojan Horse story for me, elevator-pitch style. I'd never heard of it. But a guy I was with backstage, a producer I know from the BBC, he had. And he jumped in as Hamza was talking. Yeah, yeah, Trojan Horse, he said. That was a big thing a while ago. Some bad stuff went down. Muslim educators had been up to no good. But it was cleared up. Old story.
我当时不知道。总之，哈姆扎像做电梯推介那样跟我说了“特洛伊木马”的故事。我从未听说过。但和我一起在后台的一个BBC制片人朋友听说过。在哈姆扎说话时他插了进来。他说，是的，是的，特洛伊木马，那很久以前是件大事。发生了些坏事。穆斯林教育工作者没干好事。但后来都澄清了。老掉牙的故事了。
There was something Hamza said though, which afterwards I couldn't get out of my head. He kept talking about a letter which had set off this whole cascade of consequences whose origins were still a mystery. So when I got home to New York, I read the letter.
不过哈姆扎说的话里有些东西，事后我怎么也忘不掉。他一直在谈论一封信，它引发了一连串后果，而这些后果的源头至今还是个谜。所以当我回到纽约后，我读了那封信。
It looked like a caricature of a missive between two terrorists, filled with Islamophobic tropes about conniving and scheming Muslims. It's missing pages. Parts of it are too dark to read, like it got jammed in the Xerox machine. It instructs the recipient to destroy it after reading.
它看起来像是一封伪造的恐怖分子之间通讯的讽刺画，充满了关于狡诈和阴谋穆斯林的伊斯兰恐惧症套路。信件丢失了页面。有些地方模糊到无法辨认，就像是被卡在复印机里了一样。它还要求收件人在读完后销毁它。
It struck me as a funky document for a government to take seriously, especially because, from what I read, the government hadn't even looked into who wrote the letter or why. There was a strange lack of curiosity about this instigating document. I thought to myself, seems like somebody should try to figure out who wrote that thing. And then I thought, well, wait, this journalism student's doing that. Maybe I ought to give him a hand.
我觉得政府竟然把这份古怪的文件当回事，真是太奇怪了，尤其是据我所读，政府甚至没有调查过是谁写的这封信以及为什么写。对于这份诱发事端的文件，竟然有一种奇怪的缺乏好奇心。我心想，看来总得有人试着查查到底是谁写的那玩意儿。然后我心想，等等，这个新闻系学生正在做这件事。或许我该帮他一把。
And here we are years later, at the end of a dizzying, farcical, and enraging investigation, in which one mystery led to another, led to another, tracing this letter's path of destruction across multiple continents--
然后我们就在多年后，站在了一场令人眩晕、荒诞且令人愤怒的调查终点，一个谜团引向另一个谜团，追溯着这封信在多个大洲留下的毁灭轨迹——
--in defiance of many unhappy officials and some aggressive attempts to shut our reporting down.
——在许多不满的官员的阻挠和一些试图阻止我们报道的强硬手段面前。
From Serial Productions and The New York Times, I'm Brian Reed.
来自Serial Productions和《纽约时报》，我是布莱恩·里德。
I'm Hamza Syed.
我是哈姆扎·赛义德。
Presenting to you the most elaborate student project ever, this is The Trojan Horse Affair.
向大家呈现史上最复杂的学生项目，这就是《特洛伊木马事件》。
I got the call from Brian while I was in class. My phone started ringing from a New York number. I asked my professor if I could take it. He said no. I asked if I could go use a toilet. He said yes.
我是在上课时接到布莱恩电话的。我的手机开始响起纽约的来电。我问教授能不能接个电话。他说不行。我问能不能去趟洗手间。他说可以。
I answered. And Brian told me he wanted in on my investigation, but that I would need a producer. I said, yeah, sure, all casual. I had no idea what a producer did. Soon, he started getting in touch, with missions for me to complete. The first one, he'd secured a recorder for me in Birmingham and said there was something I had to do.
我接了电话。布莱恩告诉我他想加入我的调查，但我需要一个制片人。我说，好啊，没问题，表现得很随意。我根本不知道制片人是干什么的。很快，他开始和我联络，给我布置任务。第一个任务是，他在伯明翰为我搞到了一台录音机，并说有一件事我必须要做。
It was supposed to be a basic, bread-and-butter assignment, go record a meeting. Hamza had seen an event advertised called Trojan Horse, the Facts, where some of the educators who'd been accused of carrying out the plot would be speaking publicly.
这本该是一项基本的、入门级的任务：去录一场会议。哈姆扎看到一个名为“特洛伊木马：真相”的活动广告，一些被指控实施该阴谋的教育者将公开演讲。
They insisted the Trojan Horse Affair was just an Islamophobic stitch-up. The event hashtag was #TrojanHoax. And they were trying to clear their names. They'd never gotten their lives back on track after the story had died down. They'd lost their jobs and been made into pariahs by the national media.
他们坚持认为“特洛伊木马事件”只是一场针对伊斯兰的构陷。活动标签是#特洛伊骗局。他们正试图洗清自己的名声。在故事热度平息后，他们的生活再也没能回到正轨。他们丢了工作，被主流媒体打造成了社会的弃儿。
But afterwards, Hamza calls me and says when he showed up at the spot, a community center, at 5:00 PM, the receptionist told him--
但事后，哈姆扎打电话告诉我说，当他下午5点到达那个活动地点（一个社区中心）时，接待员告诉他——
It's been canceled. The event's been canceled.
活动取消了。活动已经被取消了。
Did they give you any-- well, wait. Did they give you any other information? Like, what--
他们给了你任何——等一下。他们有没有给你提供其他信息？比如，什么——
No. They just said it's been canceled. And that was it. I said, no, this is-- you know, I spoke to the event organizer a few days ago. They said, yeah, it got canceled today. So I felt like an idiot, to be honest. Because I'm standing there with this big mic stand that looks like a fishing rod. I got my box of equipment.
没有。他们只说取消了。就这样。我说，不，我几天前刚和活动组织者谈过。他们说，是的，今天才被取消的。老实说，我觉得自己像个白痴。因为我站在那里，手里拿着那个看起来像钓鱼竿的大麦克风架。我带着装设备的箱子。
This can't be a good omen, I thought, to mess up your first journalism assignment. But then more people started showing up, confused like me. Until a man in one of those safety vests swings around the corner, tells us to follow him, and takes us up the street to a wedding hall where everyone was gathering instead. It's a lot of people, maybe over 100. And, as I explained to Brian, while I'm setting up the microphone--
我心想，这可不是什么好兆头，竟然搞砸了第一个新闻作业。但后来有更多人开始出现，像我一样困惑。直到一个穿着荧光安全背心的男人转过拐角，叫我们跟着他，把我们带到街上一间婚礼大厅，原来大家都聚在那里。人很多，可能超过100个。而且，就像我向布莱恩解释的那样，我当时正在架设麦克风——
--I start catching all the whispers, in terms of what happened. And it turned out that the original venue had received phone calls from the national newspapers, specifically this guy, Nick Timothy.
——我开始听到各种关于发生了什么的窃窃私语。结果发现原来的场地收到了来自全国性报纸的电话，具体来说是一个叫尼克·蒂莫西的人。
He's like a reporter or a publisher? Or what is he?
他是记者还是发行商？或者他是干什么的？
He's a columnist, I think, for The Telegraph.
我想他是《每日电讯报》的专栏作家。
And not just any old columnist. Nick Timothy used to be the chief of staff to the prime minister. He was essentially Teresa May's right-hand man. I spoke to the guy who ran the community center, who told me Nick Timothy had actually emailed, not called. He wouldn't let me see the email. But according to others at the meeting, the implication was, if you hold this event, I will associate you with extremists in the newspaper. And the community center pulled the plug.
而且不仅仅是普通的专栏作家。尼克·蒂莫西曾是首相的幕僚长。他本质上是特蕾莎·梅的左膀右臂。我和那个经营社区中心的人谈过，他告诉我尼克·蒂莫西实际上是发了邮件，而不是打电话。他不让我看那封邮件。但据会议上的其他人说，暗示的意思是：如果你举办这个活动，我就会在报纸上把你和极端分子联系起来。于是社区中心撤资了。
Nick Timothy denies contacting the community center and says he doesn't know who did or what they said. But he wrote a triumphant column about the planned meeting which I'd missed because I was on YouTube all day watching instructional videos on how to use my recorder, in which he noted, quote, "When the Daily Telegraph discovered this and contacted the owners of the venue, they rightly cancelled it." He went on to suggest the event organizers were extremists and described the proposed meeting as, quote, "a shocking attempt to deny the Trojan Horse scandal," and, quote, "the people behind the Trojan Horse are trying to do it all over again, and right under our noses."
尼克·蒂莫西否认联系过该社区中心，并表示他不知道是谁联系的或者说了什么。但他写了一篇关于这个原定会议的得意洋洋的专栏文章，我错过了它，因为我当时整天都在YouTube上看录音机的使用教学视频。他在文章中写道：“当《每日电讯报》发现这一点并联系了场地所有者时，他们正确地取消了活动。”他接着暗示活动组织者是极端分子，并将提议的会议描述为：“对‘特洛伊木马’丑闻令人震惊的否认尝试”，以及“‘特洛伊木马’背后的人正试图在我们的眼皮底下重演这一切”。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Good evening, ladies and gentlemen. And welcome to Trojan Horse or Hoax, the discussion and debate.
大家晚上好。欢迎参加关于“特洛伊木马事件”是事实还是骗局的讨论辩论。
So here they were, the teachers and school volunteers allegedly behind Operation Trojan Horse, along with their defenders, academics and activists and an educational barrister and a union leader, packed in this wedding hall instead.
所以他们就在这里，那些据称是“特洛伊木马行动”背后主谋的教师和学校志愿者，以及他们的支持者、学者、活动家、教育律师和工会领袖，都挤在这间婚礼大厅里。
I am really, really concerned that simply holding a public open meeting like this becomes controversial. Just the fact we are holding this meeting seems to be an act of resistance right now.
我真的非常担忧，仅仅举办这样一场公开的会议就会引发争议。仅仅是我们正在举办这场会议，似乎就变成了一种抵抗行为。
The people at this meeting called for an inquiry to correct the record on the Trojan Horse affair. They believed the government had set them up. So the fact that a former chief of staff to the prime minister, Nick Timothy, went out of his way to attack a grassroots event at a community center years after the Trojan Horse Affair, it just reinforced their suspicion-- and mine, quite honestly-- that there was something dodgy that authorities were still keen to hide.
参加这次会议的人呼吁进行调查，以纠正关于“特洛伊木马事件”的记录。他们相信政府陷害了他们。所以，尼克·蒂莫西（首相的前幕僚长）在“特洛伊木马事件”多年后还专门攻击一个社区中心的草根活动，这一事实强化了他们的怀疑——坦白说，也强化了我的怀疑——当局一定还隐藏着什么可疑的东西。
And then it was like a witch hunt. Heads were rolling this way and that way.
然后就像是一场猎巫行动。大人物们一个接一个地倒下了。
Hamza sent me the recording of the meeting. I listened to it. And I was interested to hear that one of the people who got on stage and spoke was the man named repeatedly in the Trojan Horse letter as the mastermind of Operation Trojan Horse, the plot's alleged ringleader, a longtime school volunteer named Tahir Alam.
哈姆扎发给了我会议的录音。我听了。我很有兴趣听到，其中一位上台发言的人正是“特洛伊木马信”中被反复点名作为“特洛伊木马行动”策划者的人，即所谓的阴谋主谋，一位名叫塔希尔·阿拉姆的长期学校志愿者。
I've never been a danger to anyone. I've never hurt anyone. I've never had any police case against me or anything of the kind. I wasn't running a plot. We are very proud of what we did in these schools. I do not regret nor apologize for anything that I've done. There was nothing clandestine, hidden, or sinister about what we were doing. We were very open and very transparent.
我从未对任何人构成危险。我从未伤害过任何人。我没有任何警方案件记录或类似的事情。我没有策划什么阴谋。我们为在这些学校所做的事情感到自豪。我对我所做的一切不后悔，也不道歉。我们所做的事情没有任何隐秘、隐藏或邪恶之处。我们非常公开和透明。
So when I landed in Birmingham to begin reporting, that's who we decided to go to first, Tahir Alam. We figured, we're looking to find the source of this mysterious letter. Might as well start with the guy it outed as an extremist plotter.
所以当我降落在伯明翰开始报道时，我们决定首先去找的就是塔希尔·阿拉姆。我们想，我们正试图找到这封神秘信件的源头。不如从那个被信中指为极端阴谋家的人开始调查。
Is this about to be the first radio interview you've ever done?
这会是你做的第一次电台采访吗？
Yeah. I need to be schooled beforehand, mate.
是啊。哥们，我得先补补课。
What do you mean? Like, how so?
什么意思？怎么补？
Well, I mean, if this is me flying solo, I would be like, well, whatever. I'll just do it my style, you know. But this is--
嗯，我的意思是，如果是我一个人单干的话，我会想，好吧，随便啦。我就按我的风格来，你知道。但这可是——
And what is your style? Do you have a style?
你的风格是什么？你有风格吗？
I don't know. I feel like I'm a lot--
我不知道。我觉得我——
How many of these have you done?
你做过多少次这种采访了？
None.
一次也没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But I have an idea in my head of what my style could be. I think you're a lot more sensitive than I am, put it that way. Do you know what I mean? Like, you're--
但我脑子里对我的风格有个概念。我觉得你比我敏感得多，这么说吧。你知道我的意思吗？比如，你——
I'm the more sensitive one?
我是比较敏感的那个？
I think so. Don't you think so?
我想是吧。你不这么认为吗？
I don't know. I don't know you that well.
我不知道。我不够了解你。
I wonder what he'll be wearing.
我在想他会穿什么。
[DOORBELL]
[门铃声]
Salaam, Tahir, salaam.
赛拉姆（你好），塔希尔。
Hello.
你好。
Ill-fitting button-down shirt, khakis.
穿着不合身的纽扣衬衫，卡其裤。
Welcome.
欢迎。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You're going to be in that room there.
你要坐在那个房间里。
This room?
这个房间？
We kick off our shoes. He shows us to a room at the front of his place.
我们脱掉鞋子。他带我们去了他家前边的一个房间。
Sorry you have to sit on slightly uncomfortable chairs there.
很抱歉你们得坐稍微有点不舒服的椅子。
Hamza and I squeeze behind two school desks meant for children. There are protractors lying around, a whiteboard with sketches of geometric shapes, a creative writing workbook titled "Descriptosaurus." Tahir's converted this room from his garage into a tiny makeshift classroom, where it appears he tutor students quietly. Because one result of the Trojan Horse letter is that the government has banned him from ever volunteering or working officially in schools again.
哈姆扎和我挤在两张为孩子们准备的书桌后面。周围放着量角器，一块画着几何图形草图的白板，还有一本名为《描述龙》的创意写作练习册。塔希尔把这个房间从车库改造成了一个微型临时教室，看起来他平时就在这里安静地辅导学生。因为“特洛伊木马信”的一个后果就是政府禁止他再在学校担任志愿者或正式工作。
Tahir's in front of us in his office chair, confident, erudite, framed by his bookshelf filled with texts about Islam and British history. I pull a copy of the letter out of my backpack.
塔希尔自信、博学地坐在我们面前的办公椅上，背景是一排书架，上面摆满了关于伊斯兰和英国历史的书籍。我从背包里掏出一份信的复印件。
You know, it's a completely anonymous letter, undated, claiming that there is a plot to take over and Islamize the schools in Birmingham, led by Tahir Alam, which is myself. But I speak from a vantage point where I actually know the truth. I know the reality.
你知道，这是一封完全匿名的信，没有日期，声称有一个由我，也就是塔希尔·阿拉姆领导的夺取并“伊斯兰化”伯明翰学校的阴谋。但我站在一个实际上知道真相的角度说话。我知道现实情况。
Tahir denies being an extremist. He denies engineering a plot. He says the reality is that, rather than corrupting schools as a radical conspirator, he, a first generation immigrant from a poor Pakistani family, was responsible for one of the most miraculous school turnarounds in British education. Until, he says, the letter arrived and destroyed him.
塔希尔否认自己是极端分子。他否认策划了一个阴谋。他说事实是，他并非像一个激进的阴谋家那样破坏学校，他作为一个来自贫穷巴基斯坦家庭的第一代移民，其实负责了英国教育史上最奇迹般的学校扭转之一。直到他说，那封信出现并摧毁了他。
The story of this turnaround, it's not a secret. It's one Tahir shared with journalists before, not that it's done much good, in terms of clearing his name. But this back story does explain why the Trojan Horse letter was so persuasive. Because, Tahir told us, some of what was in that letter was true.
关于这个转变的故事，并不是什么秘密。塔希尔以前也和记者分享过，但这对他洗清名声并没有多大帮助。但这段背景故事确实解释了为什么“特洛伊木马信”如此具有说服力。因为塔希尔告诉我们，信里有些内容是真的。
Tahir begins the story one night in 1993 when he's watching TV, and a show caught his attention.
塔希尔从1993年的一晚开始讲起，当时他正在看电视，一个节目吸引了他的注意。
I just happened to be just lying on the sofa, really, and the program came on.
我当时正好躺在沙发上，然后那个节目就开始了。
It was a documentary, part of the BBC series, Panorama.
那是一部纪录片，BBC系列节目《广角镜》的一部分。
9 times out of 10, I would switch to something else. But I was just sitting there and I started watching.
十有八九，我会换到别的频道。但我当时就坐在那儿，开始看了起来。
Britain's new underclass is Asian and it's Muslim. A once tightly knit community is now in crisis, with drug abuse, crime, and family breakdown on the increase.
英国的新下层阶级是亚洲人，而且是穆斯林。一个曾经紧密团结的社区现在陷入了危机，药物滥用、犯罪和家庭破裂都在增加。
And the title of this documentary was Underclass in Purdah.
这部纪录片的标题是《面纱下的下层阶级》。
In tonight's Panorama, we investigate an underclass in Purdah.
在今晚的《广角镜》中，我们调查了“面纱下的下层阶级”。
Purdah meaning cover, meaning a veil, if you like. "Underclass in the Veil," yeah?
“面纱”意味着遮盖，如果你愿意，也就是伊斯兰的面纱。“面纱下的下层阶级”，是吧？
In tonight's program, we lift the veil on this new underclass. A report from the--
在今晚的节目中，我们将揭开这个新下层阶级的面纱。一份来自——
The documentary opens with shots of Brown men skulking around dark cobblestone streets in a Muslim neighborhood, in what the correspondent calls the Muslim ghetto.
纪录片的开头是棕色皮肤男人在穆斯林社区黑暗鹅卵石街道上徘徊的镜头，通讯记者称之为“穆斯林贫民窟”。
At night, it doubles as the local red-light district.
到了晚上，这里就成了当地的红灯区。
[SIREN]
[警笛声]
It's a seedy world of vice and illicit drug dealing. Lurking in the shadows is a new Manningham phenomenon, the Pakistani pimp.
这是一个充满邪恶和非法毒品交易的肮脏世界。潜伏在阴影中的是新的曼宁汉姆现象：巴基斯坦皮条客。
He's like a regular pimp, but in a kurta.
他就像普通的皮条客，只不过穿着库尔塔长袍。
Part of the documentary takes place in Tahir's neighborhood in Birmingham, called Alum Rock, on the east side of the city. It's one of the poorest areas in England, and it's majority Pakistani and Muslim. If you're not from Birmingham and you're not Brown, you may have heard that Alum Rock is a great place to find a terrorist. If you're not from Birmingham and you are Brown, you'll have heard Alum Rock is a great place to find a wedding dress.
纪录片的一部分发生在塔希尔居住的伯明翰街区，叫做阿鲁姆罗克，位于城市的东侧。它是英格兰最贫穷的地区之一，主要居住着巴基斯坦人和穆斯林。如果你不是来自伯明翰，也不是棕色皮肤，你可能听说过阿鲁姆罗克是寻找恐怖分子的好地方。如果你不是来自伯明翰，但你是棕色皮肤，你会听说阿鲁姆罗克是买婚纱的好地方。
Admittedly, this BBC documentary is racist in a '90s TV kind of way. But it had a big impact on Tahir because, amidst the awkward Brown gazing, some truly sobering facts emerge. The presenter reports that Pakistani Muslims are incarcerated at disproportionately high rates. She says they have some of the highest rates of joblessness. They're suffering from devastating health issues, terrible housing, domestic violence, with one underlying cause of it all, a lack of education.
不得不承认，这部BBC纪录片带有90年代那种电视特有的种族主义色彩。但它对塔希尔产生了巨大的影响，因为在那些笨拙的审视目光中，出现了一些真正令人清醒的事实。主持人报道称，巴基斯坦穆斯林被监禁的比例高得不成比例。她说他们有最高的失业率。他们饱受毁灭性的健康问题、恶劣的住房、家庭暴力的困扰，而这一切的一个根本原因就是教育匮乏。
This is the number I found more shocking. About 20% of white students were leaving school without any qualifications, meaning they failed to pass exams that would essentially be the equivalent of a high school diploma in the US. And that rate, 20%, was roughly the same for most people of color as well.
这是我发现更令人震惊的数字。大约20%的白人学生离开学校时没有任何资格证书，意味着他们没有通过考试，这在本质上等同于美国的某种高中文凭。而这个20%的比例，对于大多数有色人种来说也大致相同。
But for Pakistanis and Bangladeshis, an astonishing 50% hold no qualifications whatsoever.
但对于巴基斯坦人和孟加拉人，竟有惊人的50%没有任何资格证书。
50%, half of us, were basically failing school. That hit Tahir hard.
50%，也就是我们一半的人，基本上在学校教育中失败了。这给了塔希尔沉重一击。
That the extent of education failure was so bad that we were at risk of creating an underclass of Muslims who were basically uneducated, prone to crime and unemployment. So I kind of sat there, and it made me feel guilty, actually. Guilt because I was one of the few people who made it-- from my family, one of the first ones to make it into university and to have a good job, and so on. But there was also a sense of humiliation, really, because I was from this community.
教育失败的程度如此严重，以至于我们面临着创造一个基本上受教育程度低、易于犯罪和失业的穆斯林下层阶级的风险。所以我当时就坐在那里，感到内疚，真的。内疚是因为我是为数不多成功的人之一——在我家庭中，我是第一批进入大学并拥有一份好工作等等的人。但同时也有一种屈辱感，因为我来自这个社区。
Tahir's family brought him to England in the '70s when lots of people from Kashmir were moving here, largely because the British designed this huge dam that flooded swaths of land and displaced tens of thousands of people. And one solution the Brits got behind was to invite displaced Pakistanis over to England so they could improve the British economy by working in British factories and mills.
塔希尔的家人在70年代把他带到了英国，当时许多来自克什米尔的人正在搬到这里，主要是因为英国人设计了一座巨大的大坝，淹没了大片土地，流离失所了数万人。英国人支持的一个解决方案是邀请这些流离失所的巴基斯坦人来到英国，以便他们能通过在英国工厂和磨坊工作来改善英国经济。
Which is what Tahir's dad did. Tahir arrived in England as a nine-year-old who didn't speak any English and wouldn't become fluent for several years.
这正是塔希尔父亲所做的。塔希尔九岁时来到英国，不会说任何英语，好几年后才变得流利。
I knew one word of English only, which was F-O-R-D. I mean, I don't know X-Y-Z, but I know F-O-R-D. That's it.
我只知道一个英语单词，就是“福特（FORD）”。我是说，我不知道X-Y-Z，但我知道“福特”。就这些。
I can relate. I couldn't speak any English when I first came here.
我能感同身受。我刚来这里时也不会说任何英语。
All right.
好吧。
I couldn't even speak "Ford." I was just, like, mute. "Football," that's what I knew, "football."
我连“福特”都不会说。我就像个哑巴。“足球”，这就是我懂的，“足球”。
That's right. So that's how you arrived here. And the first school, when I came here, we arrived--
没错。所以这就是你刚来这里时的样子。第一所学校，当我来到这里时，我们到达——
--potentially the biggest ethnic group in the country is growing up angry and alienated from white society.
——可能这个国家最大的少数族裔群体正在变得愤怒，并与白人社会产生隔阂。
Now Tahir watched as the documentary captured the next generation, Pakistani kids who were born in Britain, being educated in state schools, still struggling to read, not able to recall basic English words.
现在塔希尔看着纪录片捕捉到了下一代：在英国出生、在公立学校受教育的巴基斯坦孩子，仍然难以阅读，甚至无法回想起基本的英语单词。
The camera cuts to a park in Birmingham. It looked to Tahir like Ward End Park, which is right across from where he went to school in Alum Rock.
镜头切换到伯明翰的一个公园。在塔希尔看来，那就像是沃德恩公园，就在他上学的地方阿鲁姆罗克对面。
I recognized the park because we used to go and play there. And then I saw some children. And I said, oh, that's our neighbors' children. I recognized the kids, yeah, even though it was from a distance. But I recognized who the kids are.
我认出了那个公园，因为我们过去常去那里玩。然后我看到了一些孩子。我说，哦，那是我们邻居的孩子。我认出了那些孩子，是的，尽管是从远处看的。但我确实认出了他们是谁。
We filmed an encounter with two Asian lads in a park in a Muslim quarter of Birmingham.
我们拍摄了一次在伯明翰一个穆斯林社区公园里与两名亚裔少年的邂逅。
These Asian lads-- we use "Asian" to mean South Asian, by the way-- they're skipping school. And Tahir knew which school they were skipping. It's the one he'd gone to as a kid, right next to that park, Park View School, another majority-Muslim school with miserable academic results. It's a secondary school, ages 11 to 16. It was a school where Tahir had done well enough to make it to college and then university before getting a good job in telecommunications. The documentary made him realize how rare his success was and how little he'd done with it.
这些亚裔少年——顺便说一下，我们用“亚洲人”来指代南亚人——他们正在逃学。而塔希尔知道他们逃的是哪所学校。那就是他小时候去的那所学校，就在那个公园旁边，公园景观中学，另一所穆斯林占多数且成绩糟糕的学校。这是一所中学，年龄在11到16岁之间。那所学校里，塔希尔表现得足够好，从而考上了学院，然后进入大学，最终在电信行业获得了一份好工作。纪录片让他意识到他的成功是多么罕见，而他自己又做了多么少的事情。
So Tahir decided to do something. He started a tutoring program for kids in the neighborhood. But what he was really interested in was volunteering at his old school, Park View, on what's known as their governing body. In England, a governing body oversees how a school is run, like a corporate board does a company. It's sort of like a school board in the US, except it's specific to one school. They can have a lot of influence.
所以塔希尔决定做点什么。他开始为社区里的孩子们开展辅导计划。但他真正感兴趣的是去他曾经的学校——公园景观中学，在所谓的“管理委员会”做志愿者。在英格兰，管理委员会监管学校的运营方式，就像企业董事会管理公司一样。这有点像美国的学校董事会，只是它专门针对某一所学校。他们可以产生很大的影响。
So anyway, Tahir says one afternoon a couple of Park View parents he didn't know knocked on his door. We hear you're interested in becoming a governor, they said. It was like they'd read his mind. Though, actually, Tahir had been talking about wanting to be a governor at a recent wedding, and these parents got wind of it.
总之，塔希尔说一天下午，有两位他不认识的公园景观中学家长敲了他的门。他们说，听说你有兴趣成为校董。就像他们读懂了他的心一样。虽然事实上，塔希尔在最近的一场婚礼上提到过想成为校董，而这些家长听到了。
Resentment and frustration had been festering for years among parents in Alum Rock, who'd been trying and trying to get the authorities to do something about the dismal schools. These parents at Tahir's door had joined the Park View governing body in an attempt to make a change. But they didn't speak fluent English and hadn't gone to university. Tahir was a professional with a degree who still lived in the neighborhood.
阿鲁姆罗克的家长们多年来一直积压着怨恨和挫败感，他们一直试图让当局采取行动改善这些糟糕的学校。找上门来的这些家长已经加入了公园景观中学管理委员会，试图做出改变。但他们不流利地说英语，也没上过大学。塔希尔是一位受过高等教育的专业人士，并且仍然住在社区里。
We'd love to propose you, they told him. And with that, Tahir found himself at the next governing body meeting of Park View School, being voted in not only as a member but as the chair.
我们非常希望提议你参选，他们告诉他。就这样，塔希尔发现自己出现在公园景观中学的下一次管理委员会会议上，不仅被投票选为成员，还被选为主席。
So that's when I became a governor, on the 7th of January, 1997.
所以那就是我成为校董的时候，1997年1月7日。
You remember the date?
你还记得日期？
Yeah, well, I was to remain there for 18 years.
是啊，嗯，我会在那里待上18年。
When Tahir started, Park View was one of the worst secondary schools in the country. Only 4% of students were passing, 4%. The National School Inspection Agency had recently placed the school into special measures, the lowest possible ranking, an emergency status, basically, meaning Park View was in danger of being shut down.
塔希尔刚开始时，公园景观中学是全国最差的中学之一。只有4%的学生通过考试，仅仅4%。全国学校督查机构最近将该校列入“特殊措施”名单，这是可能的最低排名，本质上是一种紧急状态，意味着公园景观中学面临倒闭的危险。
There were brawls breaking out in the schoolyard. On a tour of the building, Tahir saw vandalized bathrooms with stalls missing locks and toilets missing seats. But where Tahir really trained his focus was on the complacent teachers and administrators.
校园里打架斗殴不断。在参观校舍时，塔希尔看到被破坏的厕所，隔间门锁不见了，马桶盖也没了。但塔希尔真正把焦点集中在那些自满的教师和管理人员身上。
We initially just started by saying that, obviously, children should be achieving higher, that the achievement was not acceptable, and the fact that the school was to blame for the failure.
我们最初只是说，很明显，孩子们应该取得更高的成就，成绩无法接受，而且学校本身对这种失败负有责任。
This statement, so obvious to Tahir, that the kids in Alum Rock were as capable as kids anywhere, was met with massive resistance.
这个对塔希尔来说如此显而易见的陈述——阿鲁姆罗克的孩子们和其他任何地方的孩子一样有能力——却遭到了巨大的抵制。
It was very difficult getting the school to accept that they were the problem. People didn't want to accept that because they'd been blaming the community for maybe two decades. They had such a low expectation of children.
让学校承认他们自己是问题所在是非常困难的。人们不想接受这一点，因为他们可能已经把错误归咎于社区二十年了。他们对孩子们的期望值低得令人发指。
One thing Tahir noticed early on was that the staff of this school with nearly 90% Pakistani students had only one full-time Pakistani Muslim teacher. So Tahir begin searching for more Muslim staff and governors. He gave presentations, held workshops. He became a fixture at events around East Birmingham, standing behind his little table or booth, evangelizing for people to get involved in their local schools.
塔希尔早期注意到的一件事是，这所拥有近90%巴基斯坦学生的学校里，只有一名全职的巴基斯坦穆斯林教师。因此，塔希尔开始寻找更多的穆斯林教职员工和校董。他做演讲，举办研讨会。他成了东伯明翰各地活动中的常客，站在自己的小桌子或摊位后，热切地呼吁人们参与到当地学校中去。
I loved it. [LAUGHS] I loved it with the children because I felt as though I could make a difference.
我喜欢那样。[笑] 我喜欢和孩子们在一起，因为我觉得我可以做出改变。
This is Moz Hussain, the first Muslim teacher Tahir hired. He taught math.
这是莫兹·侯赛因，塔希尔聘请的第一位穆斯林教师。他教数学。
I could use my language, my background, my understanding of where they come from, to make a difference. I knew their families.
我可以用我的语言、我的背景、我对他们出身的理解来做出改变。我了解他们的家庭。
Moz can point to a specific moment, by the way, when he decided to go into teaching.
顺便说一下，莫兹可以指出一个特定的时刻，那时他决定投身教学。
There was a Panorama program. It's called An Underclass in Purdah.
那是一个《广角镜》节目。题目是《面纱下的下层阶级》。
Powerful segment.
强有力的片段。
Moz Hussain says from the very beginning he encountered serious prejudices among the mostly white staff.
莫兹·侯赛因说，从一开始，他就遇到过大部分白人教职工中严重的偏见。
I had a group of children come to me. And they said, look, there's this one teacher in school. He always calls us Pakis. He's calling us Pakis. He's doing it in a jokey way, but we find it offensive. They're not able to tell anyone else, but they're telling me that, look, he's swearing at us.
有一组孩子来找我。他们说，看，学校里有一个老师。他总是叫我们“巴基人（Paki，带有侮辱性）”。他叫我们“巴基人”。他以开玩笑的方式说，但我们觉得这很冒犯。他们没法告诉别人，但他们告诉我，看，他是在辱骂我们。
That's a slur in any context, but especially shocking for a teacher to say to Pakistani students. Moz told them, I think the best thing to do, have your parents write the school. He talked them through the procedure for doing that, in case their parents didn't know. He says eventually the school looked into the teacher's behavior.
那是任何语境下的污蔑，尤其是对巴基斯坦学生说这种话，简直令人震惊。莫兹告诉他们，我想最好的办法是让你们的父母给学校写信。他向他们讲解了这样做的方法，以防他们的父母不知道。他说，最终学校调查了该教师的行为。
And while they were investigating, he resigned. And he gave his final leaving speech in the staff room. And goes, it should be our culture dominant in this school, not the kids. And he finished off with the words, the West is the best. And all teachers clapped. All teachers clapped.
当他们调查时，他辞职了。他在员工休息室发表了最后的辞别演讲。他说，应该是我们的文化在学校占主导地位，而不是孩子们的文化。最后他说了一句：“西方是最好的。”所有的老师都鼓掌了。所有的老师都鼓掌了。
The racism was pervasive. Razwan Faraz, a former governor and math teacher, says at one of his first governing body meetings he was shown a list of places the students had been given work placements through a program at the school. And it was all restaurants, supermarkets, clothing stores.
种族主义随处可见。拉兹万·法拉兹，一位前校董和数学老师说，在他参加的第一次管理委员会会议之一上，他被展示了一份学生通过学校项目获得实习工作的地点名单。名单上全是餐馆、超市、服装店。
And there was no surgery, doctor surgery, or law firm, or anything like that. And I said, how is it that-- did the children decide these?
没有手术室、医生诊所、律师事务所之类的地方。我说，怎么会是这样？是孩子们自己决定的吗？
And Razwan says the vice chair told him--
拉兹万说，副主席告诉他——
Well, their parents want them to go and become doctors, and engineers, and et cetera. But reality is, these kids will become taxi drivers, shopkeepers, so we've got to prepare them now.
嗯，他们的父母想让他们成为医生、工程师等等。但现实是，这些孩子将来会成为出租车司机、店主，所以我们必须现在就开始为他们做准备。
And for a good while I was struggling to process what he was saying. This is me, a Brown person, and a Muslim, and he's saying to me that they deserve to have these kind of jobs.
好长一段时间，我都很难理解他在说什么。我，一个棕色皮肤的人，一个穆斯林，他竟然对我说，他们就只配有这种工作。
This is this community's role in society, basically.
这本质上就是这个社区在社会中的角色。
That's right.
就是这样。
We just failed the kids. We just failed the kids. And didn't even feel bad about it. Didn't even-- we didn't. Didn't even feel guilty.
我们只是辜负了孩子们。我们辜负了孩子们。甚至连感到羞愧都没有。甚至都没有。连那种感觉都没有。
John Brockley was one of the non-Muslim teachers at Park View. He was a math teacher who'd been there since the '80s. He was frank with us about the bigotry that he and his colleagues held towards the students and their families.
约翰·布罗克利是公园景观中学的非穆斯林教师之一。他是一位自80年代就在那里的数学老师。他直率地向我们讲述了他和同事们对学生及其家庭持有的偏见。
We thought that we were a superior culture. And we looked down. We looked down on these people who didn't know about education.
我们认为我们是一种优越的文化。我们瞧不起他们。我们瞧不起这些不懂教育的人。
You're talking about yourself here?
你在这里是在说你自己吗？
I'm talking about myself, but I'm also talking about many of the people that I worked with.
我在说我自己，但我也在说许多和我共事的人。
The teachers attitudes are documented, by the way. A former headteacher of Park View-- a headteacher is what we Americans call a principal-- did a master's thesis while he was at the school, for which he collected opinions from the staff, including from John, as to why Muslim children were drastically underperforming compared to their peers.
顺便说一下，教师们的态度是有记录的。公园景观中学的一位前校长——校长是我们美国人所称的 principal——在他任职期间完成了一篇硕士论文，他收集了包括约翰在内的教职工的意见，探讨为什么穆斯林儿童比他们的同龄人表现差这么多。
In the thesis, teachers say the kids parents are ignorant, wrongly claim the students don't speak English. The teachers try for a while, one teacher said, but end up feeling like, who gives a damn. That's a quote. It makes John cringe to think back on it.
在论文中，老师们说孩子们的父母无知，错误地声称学生不会说英语。有一位老师说，老师们尝试了一段时间，但最后觉得“谁在乎呢”。这是一句引语。约翰回想起这些话时感到不寒而栗。
It's only when you when you move away from a situation like that that you can realize how awful it is. I don't normally think about this sort of thing because it's too embarrassing.
只有当你离开那样的情况时，你才能意识到那是多么可怕。我通常不愿去想这类事情，因为太尴尬了。
Once we created the shift in the belief of the teachers, then the job became much easier.
一旦我们改变了老师们的信仰，工作就变得容易多了。
Tahir says by the early 2000s, Park View was changing. The school began taking basic but transformative steps, setting individualized achievement targets for each student that followed them from year to year, and preparing students for qualifying exams which, amazingly, hadn't happened before. School started awarding trophies for good marks, inviting parents to ceremonies when their kids did well.
塔希尔说，到21世纪初，公园景观中学正在发生变化。学校开始采取基本但具有变革性的措施：为每名学生设定从一年跟到下一年的个性化成就目标，并让学生准备资格考试。这在以前是令人惊讶地从未发生过的事情。学校开始为高分学生颁发奖杯，邀请家长在孩子们表现优异时参加颁奖仪式。
Tahir and the governor's hired a new headteacher, a non-Muslim woman from a girls' school, who embraced Park View's new aspirations. Test scores started to rise. Students were heading to college. Park View's reputation was turning around. But there were other changes Tahir instituted at Park View which, later, officials would view as suspect, changes that investigators would point to as the trademarks of Operation Trojan Horse. That's coming up.
塔希尔和校董聘请了一位新校长，一位来自女子中学的非穆斯林女性，她拥抱了公园景观中学的新愿景。考试成绩开始上升。学生们纷纷考入大学。公园景观中学的名声开始好转。但塔希尔在公园景观中学实行的其他改变，后来被官员们视为可疑，这些改变被调查人员指为“特洛伊木马行动”的标志。接下来说。
Indeed it is, when Hamza and Brian return. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
确实如此，当哈姆扎和布莱恩回来时。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we are playing part 1 of the newest podcast from our sister company, Serial Productions. The show is called The Trojan Horse Affair. And we pick up with Brian and Hamza where they left off.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在节目中，我们正在播放我们姐妹公司Serial Productions最新播客的第一部分。节目名字叫《特洛伊木马事件》。让我们继续跟随布莱恩和哈姆扎的脚步。
You don't get labeled the leader of an extremist conspiracy simply by raising test scores at your neighborhood secondary school. The main accusation against Tahir Alam, the overarching assertion of the Trojan Horse letter, which the government supported and which has defined Tahir's reputation since then, is that he was Islamizing schools.
你不可能仅仅因为提高了邻里中学的考试成绩，就被贴上极端阴谋主谋的标签。针对塔希尔·阿拉姆的主要指控，即“特洛伊木马信”的核心论断，后来得到了政府的支持，并从此定义了塔希尔的名声，那就是他正在“伊斯兰化”学校。
This is not a word I'm particularly fond of, "Islamize," because Islamize in relation to what, some assumed non-Islamic baseline? Has this story been Islamized by Hamza's involvement?
我不怎么喜欢“伊斯兰化”这个词，因为相对于什么而言是“伊斯兰化”？相对于某些假设的非伊斯兰基准吗？这个故事因为哈姆扎的参与而“被伊斯兰化”了吗？
Yes.
是的。
It's a word that isn't inherently negative but gets used that way. Anyway, that's what the letter said Tahir was doing, Islamizing schools. And, funnily enough, it's also what Tahir says he was doing.
这个词本身并不带有负面含义，但却被这样使用。总之，这封信就是说塔希尔在做这件事，在“伊斯兰化”学校。而且很有趣的是，这也是塔希尔所说的他正在做的事情。
We were valuing the cultural and the faith background of the children. And we were allowing that to be expressed, if you like. We catered for children so they could perform their daytime prayers if they wanted to. We made a prayer facility available for them in a room.
我们是在重视孩子们的文化和信仰背景。如果你愿意的话，我们允许这种背景得到表达。我们为孩子们提供了便利，如果他们愿意，可以在白天进行祈祷。我们在一间房间里为他们提供了祈祷设施。
Religious accommodations like this are legal in British schools, by the way, whether they're explicitly designated as a religious school or not, which Park View wasn't. It was the equivalent of a regular public school in the US.
顺便说一下，这种宗教安排在英国学校是合法的，无论它们是否被明确指定为宗教学校，公园景观中学并不是。它相当于美国的普通公立学校。
And since 98% of the children happened to be of the Islamic faith background, we obviously are catering for the constituency that the school serves, in line with the regulatory requirements.
由于98%的孩子恰好有伊斯兰信仰背景，我们显然是在满足学校所服务的选民的需求，这符合监管要求。
Tahir ascribed to an educational philosophy that, the way he and other Park View staff talk about it, reminds me of Afrocentric or Black Excellence schools in the US, that students will do better academically when their schools incorporate and celebrate who they are. And there's research that backs this up.
塔希尔信奉一种教育哲学，按照他和公园景观中学其他员工谈论它的方式，让我想起了美国的非裔中心或“黑人卓越”学校：当学校结合并庆祝他们是谁时，学生们在学业上会做得更好。有研究支持这一结论。
So, under Tahir's leadership, Park View allowed students to pray if they wanted. They installed facilities for wudu, the ablutions you do before prayers. They celebrated Ramadan and altered the schedule during that month to facilitate fasting. They served halal food.
因此，在塔希尔的领导下，公园景观中学允许学生在他们愿意时祈祷。他们安装了“小净（Wudu，祷告前的净礼）”设施。他们庆祝斋月，并在那个月调整时间表以方便斋戒。他们提供清真食品。
And I felt that, you know, this was our school. I mean, we were proud to say that this is our school. We wanted our children to say that this was their school and that they were proud of it.
我觉得，你知道，这是我们的学校。我是说，我们很自豪地说这是我们的学校。我们希望孩子们说这是他们的学校，并且为它感到自豪。
In the wake of the Trojan Horse letter, government officials would declare that the way Tahir and his colleagues were running Park View school had undermined, quote, unquote, British values, that they were limiting the children's ability to thrive in modern Britain. Which is an interesting charge to bring against Tahir because, I have to say, I haven't personally met an English Pakistani more confident that he's British than Tahir.
在“特洛伊木马信”之后，政府官员宣称，塔希尔和同事管理公园景观中学的方式“破坏了所谓的英国价值观”，限制了孩子们在现代英国茁壮成长的能力。这对塔希尔来说是一个有趣的指控，因为我必须说，我还没有亲自见过比塔希尔更确信自己是英国人的英籍巴基斯坦人。
Deciding whether or not to call yourself British is a fraught and personal thing for us. Speaking for myself, even though I came to England when I was 8, and became a British citizen with a British passport, even though I have a British education, went to British University, worked for Britain's National Health Service, I didn't call myself British. I was never precious about nationality, so I didn't really care what I was called. But sure, I'd also picked up on the subliminal messaging that in order to be proper British you had to be white.
决定是否称自己为英国人对我们来说是一件令人揪心和私人的事情。就我个人而言，尽管我8岁就来到英国，成为了持有英国护照的英国公民，尽管我接受了英国教育，上了英国大学，为英国国家医疗服务体系工作过，我并没有称自己为英国人。我从不对国籍斤斤计较，所以我并不真正在意别人称呼我为什么。但当然，我也察觉到了那种潜意识里的暗示：要成为真正的英国人，你就必须是白人。
Tahir, on the other hand, not only calls himself British, but does so proudly. I got to talking to Tahir about this one day. He and Brian and I were getting tea at my favorite chai shop on Alum Rock Road.
而塔希尔，不仅自称为英国人，而且以此为荣。有一天我和塔希尔谈到了这一点。他和布莱恩还有我正在阿鲁姆罗克路上我最喜欢的奶茶店喝茶。
Well, this is the hangout.
嗯，这就是常聚的地方。
And as we sat outside in one of the main thoroughfares of Islamic Britain, around the corner from where Tahir grew up with double-decker buses passing by sweet shops and fabric stores and halal chippies, I told him my reason for why I'd finally, only recently, started calling myself British.
当我们坐在伊斯兰英国的主要干道之一、就在塔希尔长大的地方转角处，看着双层巴士经过糖果店、布料店和清真炸鱼薯条店时，我告诉了他我最近才开始称自己为英国人的原因。
So for a long time, I never called myself British.
所以很长一段时间里，我从不称自己为英国人。
I was about 30. I had been reading a book about the British empire. And I learned how rich India, which at the time included Pakistan, was, according to some economists, before the British took control.
我大概30岁的时候。我一直在读一本关于大英帝国的书。我了解到根据一些经济学家的说法，在英国控制之前，印度（当时包括巴基斯坦）是多么富有。
And I believe the statistic is, roughly it controlled about the 24%, or something like that, of the world's economy at the time.
我相信统计数据是，它当时控制了全球大约24%或类似比例的经济。
Yeah, 23% of the world's economy.
是的，全球经济的23%。
Right.
没错。
It was the richest nation in the world.
那是世界上最富有的国家。
Right.
没错。
24% of the world's economy is roughly what the US controls today. I know this is somewhat of an apples and oranges comparison because the world wasn't organized into a globalized economy back then. But it does show how rich India was in relation to other countries at the time. When the British left the Indian subcontinent after some 200 years of economic exploitation, India and Pakistan were among the poorest nations in the world.
全球经济的24%大致相当于美国今天控制的比例。我知道这是一个有点“苹果和橙子”的比较，因为当时的世界并没有组织成全球化的经济。但这确实显示了当时印度相对于其他国家是多么富有。当英国在经过大约200年的经济剥削离开印度次大陆后，印度和巴基斯坦成了世界上最贫穷的国家之一。
I didn't learn this stuff in school because Britain's colonization of a quarter of the planet is not compulsory part of the national curriculum, which is why I only discovered it as an adult, that so much of the wealth I saw in Britain was actually extracted from the place I come from.
我在学校没学过这些东西，因为英国对地球四分之一地区的殖民并不是国家课程的必修部分，这就是为什么我直到成年才发现，我在英国看到的这么多财富，实际上是从我来自的地方攫取的。
And so, from that point onwards, I've started calling myself British. I was just like, well, I'm British. I own this country. This is my money with which you have raised everything around me.
所以从那时起，我就开始称自己为英国人。我就觉得，好吧，我是英国人。我拥有这个国家。这就是你们用来兴建我周围一切事物的钱。
Yeah, so, I mean, that's very similar to the position I am arrived at.
是的，所以，我的意思是，这和我得出的结论非常相似。
Except, for me, proclaiming I'm British is somewhat of a finger in the eye. For Tahir, it's sincere. It also came to him later in life. He says he was at an event held by a British Muslim organization. And they began saying, very clearly, you're never going back to Pakistan. Your children are never going to move back.
不过对我来说，宣告我是英国人有点像是在眼中钉。对塔希尔来说，这是真诚的。这也发生在他生命的后期。他说当时他在参加一个英国穆斯林组织举办的活动。他们非常清楚地开始说：你们永远不会回到巴基斯坦了。你们的孩子也永远不会搬回去。
It's not going to happen.
不会发生这种事的。
That's what you had been thinking up to that point.
那也是你一直以来的想法。
Yeah, because our parents spoke like that to us. Our homes are in Pakistan. We are Pakistani. Our parents spoke to us like that. My father never told me we are British because that's not what he felt. He lived in Pakistan most of his life. Why would he say that?
是的，因为我们的父母就是那样对我们说的。我们的家在巴基斯坦。我们是巴基斯坦人。我们的父母就是那样对我们说话的。我父亲从没告诉过我我们是英国人，因为这不是他的感受。他大半辈子都生活在巴基斯坦。他为什么要那么说呢？
The people at this event were saying, you live here now.
活动上的人们说，你们现在住在这里。
We were part of this country, and that it was important, as Muslims, we should bring benefit to this country. So ever since then, I've been kind of dissing the idea that we are other, that we are outsiders, that we don't belong here. Islam is part of Britain. It's not alien. I don't accept that. Can you see? So this is why--
我们是这个国家的一部分，重要的是，作为穆斯林，我们应该为这个国家做出贡献。所以从那时起，我一直在反驳那种“我们是异类”、“我们是局外人”、“我们不属于这里”的想法。伊斯兰教是英国的一部分。它并不陌生。我不接受那种说法。你能明白吗？所以这就是为什么——
So for Tahir, not only was incorporating Islam into the school an academic strategy, it was also a British value.
所以对于塔希尔来说，把伊斯兰教纳入学校不仅是一种学术策略，也是一种英国价值观。
It was really nice for me that--
这对我来说真的很好——
It was during school?
是在学校期间吗？
--I'm doing something at home, and now my school is helping me do it.
——我在家里做某事，现在我的学校在帮我做这件事。
Yeah, like, I didn't want to have a different life at school. If I'm praying at home, I want to pray at school too because--
是的，就像，我不想在学校过另一种生活。如果我在家里祈祷，我也想在学校祈祷，因为——
These are two students who graduated from Park View in 2014. We're not using their names because such is the stink of the Trojan Horse scandal, they don't want potential employers to know where they went to school. They actually keep it off their resumes.
这两位是2014年毕业于公园景观中学的学生。我们不用他们的名字，因为“特洛伊木马”丑闻的影响太大，他们不想让潜在的雇主知道他们在哪儿上的学。他们实际上把这段经历从简历上删掉了。
When Hamza and I met them four years after they graduated, they were both studying law at university, some of the first in their families to go on to higher education. They've been best friends since school, the kind of friends who don't need words to communicate.
当哈姆扎和我见到他们毕业四年后，他们都在大学学习法律，是家中第一批接受高等教育的人。他们从学校起就是最好的朋友，那种不需要言语就能沟通的朋友。
Are you talking about-- um, yeah. I don't know if I should--
你们是在谈论——嗯，是的。我不知道我是否应该——
Oh, that.
噢，那个。
We're telepathic, basically.
基本上我们有心灵感应。
Basically.
基本上是这样。
The students told us about these assemblies they would have in the mornings, which included religious teachings and sometimes prayer.
学生们告诉我们，他们早上会有晨会，其中包括宗教教学，有时还有祈祷。
So there was this one incident--
当时发生了一件事——
This is something that, as an American, made me do a double take when I first heard about it. The idea of teachers in a public school leading prayers during assembly is not normal to us. But in Britain, there's no separation between church and state. The queen is head of both. So not only is prayer allowed in schools, some form of worship is legally mandated in all schools that are publicly funded.
这是作为一名美国人，我第一次听到时感到非常不可思议的事情。公立学校的老师在晨会时带领祈祷的概念对我们来说是不正常的。但在英国，教会和国家之间没有分离。女王是两者的元首。所以祈祷不仅在学校被允许，某种形式的礼拜在所有公共资助的学校中更是法律强制要求的。
Schools don't always adhere to this, but students are supposed to take part in what's called a daily act of collective worship. By default, it's supposed to be broadly Christian in character. But schools can apply to change it to other faiths, if that better suits their students. Which is what Park View did, it got approval for its worship to be Islamic.
学校并不总是严格遵守这一点，但学生们被要求参与所谓的“每日集体礼拜”。默认情况下，它应该是以基督教性质为主的。但学校可以申请将其改为其他信仰，如果那更适合学生的话。这就是公园景观中学所做的，它获得了伊斯兰礼拜的批准。
The students told us, at Park View's assemblies they would sit in the main hall and a teacher would tell parables or lessons, usually from Islam, but other faiths too.
学生们告诉我们，在公园景观中学的晨会上，他们会坐在大厅里，老师会讲寓言或课程，通常来自伊斯兰教，但也包括其他信仰。
Do you guys remember actually learning things in these assemblies? Or did they make you think? Or were they just kind of boring teachers blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, like--
你们记得在这些晨会上真的学到了东西吗？还是它们让你们思考？或者只是无聊的老师讲啊讲啊，像——
No, they would make us think.
不，它们会让我们思考。
I really enjoyed those assemblies because I didn't learn this from anywhere else.
我真的很喜欢那些晨会，因为我没在其他任何地方学到过这些。
They still remember this one assembly all these years later, about charity.
多年后的今天，他们仍然记得那次关于慈善的晨会。
Talking about charity, and they say when you're giving charity, put your hand in your pocket and take out. Don't look at how much you're giving. Just put it in. Don't count what you're giving and what you have left because when you give, you receive tenfold.
谈论慈善，他们说当你给予慈善时，把手伸进兜里。不要看你给了多少。放进去就好。不要去算你给了多少以及还剩下多少，因为当你给予时，你会收获十倍。
Yeah. And charity does not make you poor. Quite literally, sometimes when I, like, see somebody who is asking for money and things like that, I'll put my hand in my purse.
是的。而且慈善不会让你变穷。有时候，当我看到有人在乞讨钱财之类的时候，我会把手伸进钱包。
And take it out.
然后拿出来。
I'll take it out and I don't look at what's in it.
我会拿出来，我不看里面是什么。
I do that all the time.
我一直都这么做。
Just because I remember that one teacher. He literally said it like that.
仅仅因为我记得那个老师。他真的是那么说的。
Like that. Give so that your left hand doesn't--
就是那样。给予，让你的左手——
--know what your right hand gave.
——不知道你的右手做了什么。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Yeah.
是的。
When Tahir became chair of Park View's governing body in 1997, 4% of students were passing. By 2010, that number was 71%, a seventeenfold increase.
当塔希尔于1997年成为公园景观中学管理委员会主席时，只有4%的学生通过考试。到2010年，这个数字是71%，增长了十七倍。
We had not changed the children. We had not changed the parents. But, slowly but surely, we took the results so that they were consistently in the 70s, which means the school actually is kind of guaranteeing an outcome.
我们没有改变孩子。我们没有改变家长。但是，我们慢慢地、稳步地把成绩提上来，使它们始终保持在70%左右，这意味着学校实际上是在某种程度上保证了产出。
Park View was now actively preparing its students for the eventuality that their academic success would lead them out of East Birmingham.
公园景观中学现在正在积极准备，让学生们意识到他们的学业成功将带领他们走出东伯明翰。
Something that a lot of teachers said to me, you live in a bubble.
很多老师对我说的一句话是：你生活在一个泡沫里。
Again, the former Park View students.
还是那些前公园景观中学的学生。
And I was like, what do you mean? They were like, you live in an Asian community. You go to an Asian school.
我当时说，你什么意思？他们说，你住在一个亚洲社区。你去的是一所亚洲学校。
Yes.
是的。
You're very safe. You don't know what it's like to branch out. I remember, we learned about the population and how it's divided in UK. And I think it was something like 2% of the population in the UK is Asian. And I was like, whoa, only 2%. I was like, 2%? How is it 2%? Like, everybody I know is Asian.
你很安全。你不知道走出圈子是什么样的。我记得，我们学过人口情况以及英国的人口划分。我想大概是英国人口中2%是亚洲人。我当时想，哇，只有2%。我想，2%？怎么会是2%？我认识的每个人都是亚洲人。
Every person that I've come across is probably--
我遇到的每一个人都可能是——
Yeah.
是的。
How is that possible?
这怎么可能？
So it was so odd.
所以这太奇怪了。
The UK is actually 2% Pakistani, 7% Asian. The point being, there was a vast majority of the population that these students and their classmates were not bumping into day-to-day in Alum Rock. The school organized visits to Cambridge University. They took them on camping trips. They visited the Houses of Parliament in London. Some students went on a week long trip on a sailboat with kids from all over, including a bunch of white kids.
英国实际上有2%的巴基斯坦人，7%的亚洲人。关键是，绝大多数人口是这些学生和他们的同学在阿鲁姆罗克日常生活中碰不到的。学校组织了去剑桥大学的参观，带他们去露营，访问伦敦的国会大厦。一些学生参加了为期一周的帆船旅行，和来自各地的孩子们在一起，包括一堆白人小孩。
We weren't used to mingling with people who were not Pakistani. So they were exposing us to you guys, OK?
我们不习惯与非巴基斯坦人交往。所以他们是在让我们接触你们这些人，好吗？
You're looking at me?
你在看我吗？
This is what they were preparing us for.
这就是他们为我们做的准备。
Parents clamored to get their kids into Park View. The school had a waiting list.
家长们争先恐后地想把孩子送进公园景观中学。学校有一份等待名单。
We were given all kinds of accolades nationally, in the press. We had officials coming in and out of our school, really. They're saying, what are you doing? You know, perhaps we can learn something. And they invited us, actually. Then why don't you support other schools?
我们在全国媒体上获得了各种赞誉。官员们进进出出我们的学校，真的。他们说，你们在做什么？你知道，也许我们能学到点什么。他们甚至邀请我们。那你们为什么不支持其他学校呢？
Tahir became well regarded in education circles. And over the years, he expanded his reach beyond Park View. He was certified as an inspector for Ofsted, the agency that monitors and rates schools in Britain. The Birmingham City Council hired him to train other governors throughout the city. The national department for education even asked Tahir and his colleagues at Park View to take over two other troubled schools in East Birmingham, which they did. Tahir was invited to tea at 10 Downing Street and met Prime Minister Tony Blair. Back in Birmingham though, some people resented him.
塔希尔在教育界备受推崇。多年来，他将影响力扩展到了公园景观中学之外。他被认证为Ofsted（英国教育标准局）的检查员，这是监测和评估英国学校的机构。伯明翰市议会聘请他培训全市其他校董。国家教育部甚至要求塔希尔和他在公园景观中学的同事接管东伯明翰另外两所陷入困境的学校，他们做到了。塔希尔被邀请到唐宁街10号喝茶，并会见了首相托尼·布莱尔。但在伯明翰，有些人对他不满。
Yeah, he had made enemies of a lot of schools in the area. He became, like, hated amongst a lot of people.
是啊，他在当地成了许多学校的敌人。他在许多人眼中成了被痛恨的对象。
Moz Hussain, who became Park View's acting headteacher around this time, was a full supporter of Tahir's. But still, he and other former colleagues told us they wished Tahir was a bit more circumspect in the way he went around to other schools, advocating for reform. He was self-assured, blunt, and particularly unsparing when laying out for headteachers and other school leaders the way their schools were failing Muslim students.
莫兹·侯赛因（此时成为公园景观中学代理校长）是塔希尔的全力支持者。但即便如此，他和前同事告诉我们，他们希望塔希尔在去其他学校提倡改革时能更谨慎一点。他自信、直率，尤其是在向校长和其他学校领导指出他们的学校是如何辜负穆斯林学生时，毫不留情。
To tell other schools, look, Park View can do it. Park View can do it. Park View can do it. Same family, same children that you got, they can do it. That's not an excuse. We used to tell Tahir off for this a lot. Stop using us as a beating stick because it's isolating us amongst other schools.
去告诉其他学校，看，公园景观中学能做到。公园景观中学能做到。公园景观中学能做到。同样家庭，同样的孩子，你们也行。这不是借口。我们过去经常为此责备塔希尔。别再把我们当作敲打他们的棍子了，因为这让我们在其他学校中陷入孤立。
He was actually pointing the finger and saying directly to headteachers, you're not doing a good enough job here for these kids.
他实际上是在指责他们，并直接对校长们说，你们没有为这些孩子做好工作。
Jackie Hughes used to be in charge of school improvement for the Birmingham City Council. And she says she can name headteachers that she knows Tahir made enemies with. Many of them were used to having the final word on academics. And then here was Tahir, this volunteer with no professional teaching experience, waltzing in and criticizing their work.
杰基·休斯曾负责伯明翰市议会的学校改善工作。她说她能说出很多她知道的被塔希尔结下梁子的校长。他们习惯了在学术问题上拥有最终话语权。然后塔希尔来了，这个没有任何专业教学经验的志愿者，大摇大摆地走进来批评他们的工作。
I mean, actually, people would come to me and say, I can't understand why you'd give Tahir the time of day. He's a terrible man. He said to me, blah, blah, blah, blah. And they would go sounding off.
我的意思是，实际上，人们会找我，说：我无法理解为什么你还要理塔希尔。他是个可怕的人。他对我说，巴拉巴拉。他们会大肆抱怨。
Colleagues and friends warned Tahir, you might want to consider softening your approach. But Tahir wasn't having it.
同事和朋友警告塔希尔，你或许应该考虑软化一下你的方式。但塔希尔不吃这一套。
You have to fight for justice. Justice is not going to be handed to you on the plate. You have to make space for yourself. So the fact that some people may not be OK with that is a different-- is irrelevant to me. That's their problem.
你必须为正义而战。正义不会自动送到你盘子里。你必须为自己争取空间。所以有些人可能对此不高兴，那是另一回事——这与我无关。那是他们的问题。
In 2012, Park View received the ultimate validation. In what was probably its proudest moment in Tahir's nearly 18 years there, Ofsted arrived for an inspection and deemed the school outstanding, the highest rating possible. Among the many things inspectors praised at Park View were the, quote, "wide range of opportunities for spiritual development, including voluntary Friday prayers."
2012年，公园景观中学获得了最终的认可。在塔希尔待了近18年里可能是最自豪的时刻，Ofsted进行了视察，并将该校评为“杰出”，这是可能的最高评价。督察员们称赞公园景观中学的众多事项中包括：“提供广泛的精神发展机会，包括自愿的周五祈祷。”
In his time as chair of governors, Tahir had taken Park View from the lowest ranking, the verge of closure, to the very top. The person in charge of Ofsted, the chief inspector, said, quote, "Every school in the country should be like this."
在担任校董会主席期间，塔希尔将公园景观中学从最低排名、几乎面临倒闭提升到了最高点。Ofsted的负责人、首席督察员说：“全国每所学校都应该像这样。”
Less than two years later, on November 27, 2013, an envelope arrived on the desk of the leader of Birmingham City Council, a man named Sir Albert Bore. Inside was a cover sheet addressed to him, marked "Very Important," "Confidential."
不到两年后，2013年11月27日，一个信封送到了伯明翰市议会领导人的办公桌上，此人名叫西里·阿尔伯特·博尔。里面是一份写给他的封面，标记为“非常重要”、“机密”。
"Mr. Bore," it said, "this letter was found when I was clearing my boss's files. And I think you should be aware that I am shocked at what your officers are doing. You have seven days to investigate this matter, after which it will be sent to a national newspaper, who I'm sure will treat it seriously. Sincerely, AN." "Anonymous," presumably.
“博尔先生，”信上写道，“这封信是我在清理老板文件时发现的。我想你应该知道，我对你们官员正在做的事情感到震惊。你有七天时间调查此事，之后它将被发给一家全国性报纸，我相信他们会认真对待它的。真诚的，AN。”大概是“匿名（Anonymous）”的意思。
Behind that note was the Trojan Horse letter, four poorly copied pages, shadows at the edges, instructions to destroy after reading. The letter was written as if from a collaborator of Tahir's, describing a conspiracy Tahir had been running to take over and Islamize schools by deception.
那份便条后面是“特洛伊木马信”，四页复印得很糟糕的页面，边缘阴影重重，有读完后销毁的指令。信件的内容看起来就像是塔希尔的合作者写的，描述了一个塔希尔一直在进行的阴谋，意图通过欺骗夺取并“伊斯兰化”学校。
It took weeks for Tahir to learn about it. He heard rumors there was a mysterious letter making its way around Birmingham, around the city council and to headteachers in town, which named him as the orchestrator of a plot. One of Tahir's friends rushed to his house to tell him that he'd been getting a haircut over on Washwood Heath Road and, afterwards, his friend's barber had beckoned him into the back room of the shop and showed him a copy. Tahir did not know what to make of it. Finally, he got a hold of the document himself.
塔希尔过了几周才知道这件事。他听到传言说有一封神秘的信在伯明翰四处传播，传到了市议会和镇上的校长手中，信中点名他就是阴谋的幕后策划者。塔希尔的一位朋友赶到他家告诉他，他刚才在华什伍德希思路理发，结束后理发师把他叫进店里屋，展示了一份复印件。塔希尔不知该作何感想。最终，他自己搞到了这份文件。
You know, obviously, I was thinking, what is the source of this letter? Who wrote this letter? Why was this letter written, is what's ringing in my head.
你知道，很明显，我当时在想，这封信的来源是什么？是谁写的这封信？为什么会写这封信？这些问题在我脑子里盘旋。
The front page was missing, so there was no "Dear whoever." It just started as if it had been going on for a page or more already. And the letter ended mid-sentence too, with the phrase, "I would also like." So there's no sign-off, which meant Tahir couldn't tell exactly who it was supposed to be to or from. But whoever wrote the letter said explicitly, "Tahir and I."
首页不见了，所以没有“亲爱的谁谁”。它只是直接开始，好像已经写了一页或更多。信在句子中间也结束了，写着“我也想”。所以没有签名，这意味着塔希尔无法分辨它到底是写给谁的，或者从哪儿来的。但不管是谁写的，信中明确提到“塔希尔和我”。
It's supposed to be from somebody who knows me well in Birmingham. And he's talking to somebody in Bradford.
它看起来像是伯明翰某个非常了解我的人写的。他在和布拉德福德的人对话。
Another British city that's home to a lot of Muslims.
另一个拥有许多穆斯林的英国城市。
He's talking about Tahir, what he's done here, we can do it over there.
他在谈论塔希尔，谈论他在这里做的事，我们可以在那边也做。
And he's your friend or your associate. Or she, whoever.
而且他是你的朋友或伙伴。或者她，不管是谁。
Whoever it is, yeah.
不管是哪位，是的。
Can you keep reading just the first few paragraphs?
你能继续读一下前面几段吗？
OK. Operation Trojan Horse has been carefully thought through and is tried and tested within Birmingham. Tahir and I will be happy to support your efforts in Bradford. This is a long-term plan and one which we are sure will lead to great success in taking over a number of schools and ensuring that they are run on the strict Islamic principles. In Birmingham, the benefits--
好的。“特洛伊木马行动”经过精心策划，已在伯明翰进行了测试。塔希尔和我很高兴支持你们在布拉德福德的努力。这是一个长期的计划，我们确信这将在夺取一些学校并确保它们按严格的伊斯兰原则运行方面取得巨大成功。在伯明翰，好处——
The main tactic of Operation Trojan Horse is to target headteachers at the schools you want to take control of, to make their lives so miserable that they'll resign or else be fired. At which point, you can install your own people, who will implant Islamic extremism in the school. The author gives several examples of schools in Birmingham where Tahir and his cronies were supposedly in the middle of doing this.
“特洛伊木马行动”的主要战术是锁定你想控制的学校的校长，让他们的生活变得如此痛苦以至于他们辞职或者被解雇。届时，你就可以安装自己的人，他们会在学校植入伊斯兰极端主义。作者列举了伯明翰的几个例子，称塔希尔和他的亲信涉嫌正在那里做这些事。
"We have caused a great amount of organized disruption in Birmingham," the letter says, "and are on the way to getting rid of more headteachers and taking over their schools. While sometimes the practices we use may not seem the correct way to do things, you must remember that this is a jihad. And, as such, using all means possible to win the war is acceptable."
“我们在伯明翰引起了大量的有组织破坏，”信中说，“并且即将摆脱更多的校长并接管他们的学校。虽然有时我们使用的做法可能看起来不是正确的方式，但你必须记住这是一个‘圣战’。因此，使用一切可能的手段赢取这场战争是可以接受的。”
What was your feeling or your attitude? Were you laughing at it? Were you actually kind of taking it seriously and frightened? What was your--
你的感受或态度是什么？你在嘲笑它吗？还是你真的有点严肃对待并感到恐惧？你当时——
I wasn't laughing, actually, because I knew the serious nature of the allegations that were being made. But as far as the claims themselves were concerned, they were laughable. So I knew that there was something not right about what was going on here.
实际上我并没有笑，因为我知道这些指控的严重性。但就这些指控本身而言，它们是荒谬的。所以我知道这里发生的事情有点不对劲。
Tahir contacted the Birmingham City Council, where the letter was first sent. He'd done training for them for years.
塔希尔联系了最早收到这封信的伯明翰市议会。他多年来一直为他们提供培训。
And I said, look, I work for you. And this letter apparently is going around claiming certain things. And I'm surprised that you haven't spoken to me to at least to get my view on the matter. At least ask me to explain, or if I know anything, or whatever, or something.
我说，看，我为你们工作。但这封信显然正在流传，声称某些事情。我很惊讶你们甚至没有和我谈过，至少来听听我对这件事的看法。至少问我解释一下，或者我是否知道任何事情，或者别的什么。
And the gentleman there, actually, from the city council, he said, Mr. Alam, to be very honest with you, we don't think anything of the letter. We think it's a completely bogus hoax letter. And we don't believe there is any truth in it. And therefore we didn't take any action. We didn't do anything with it.
然后那里的那位绅士，来自市议会的，他说，阿拉姆先生，说实话，我们并不觉得这封信有什么内容。我们认为这是一封完全虚假的恶作剧信。我们不相信里面有任何真实内容。因此我们没有采取任何行动。我们没有对它做任何事情。
Did you feel reassured by that?
你觉得安心了吗？
Not really, no, because then the letter began to be printed in the national media as well.
并不，不，因为随后这封信也开始在全国媒体上被印刷出来。
Someone leaked the letter to The Sunday Times of London. And from there, it became a frenzy. One story turned to two, turned to dozens. In the Daily Mail, The Telegraph, The Spectator, Sky TV, many of them giving credence to the letter, saying that extremists like Tahir had allegedly been infiltrating UK schools for years. Reporters camped outside Park View. They stalked Tahir down the street--
有人把这封信泄露给了《伦敦星期日泰晤士报》。从那时起，它就变成了一场狂热。一个故事变成了两个，变成了几十个。《每日邮报》、《每日电讯报》、《旁观者》、《天空电视台》，许多人相信这封信，声称像塔希尔这样的极端分子涉嫌渗透英国学校多年。记者们在公园景观中学外扎营。他们在街上跟踪塔希尔——
We tried to put these allegations to the Academy's Chair of Governors, but Tahir Alam--
我们试图向学院的校董会主席提出这些指控，但塔希尔·阿拉姆——
--turned up at his house.
——出现在他家门口。
Hello.
你好。
Hello, Mr. Alam? Mr. Alam.
你好，阿拉姆先生？阿拉姆先生。
[DOOR SHUTS]
[门关上]
Hello.
你好。
The government kicked into gear too. Investigators swarmed Park View. Ofsted, the school inspector, arrived for two surprise inspections.
政府也采取了行动。调查人员涌入公园景观中学。Ofsted学校督察员进行了两次突击检查。
And then we had the education funding agency investigation, which was about 10 days, I think. They were in there for 10 days. And as soon as they left, we had PWC--
然后我们有了教育资助机构的调查，持续了大约10天，我想。他们在那里待了10天。他们刚走，我们就有了PWC——
PricewaterhouseCoopers, a big outside auditing firm.
普华永道，一家大型外部审计公司。
--looking into the financial affairs of the school. So then we had them for five weeks in the school, as well. I said, what are you looking for? I said, what are you looking for? You've been here three weeks. You must have a family.
——查看学校的财务事务。所以我们在学校里又有了他们五周。我说，你们在找什么？我说，你们在找什么？你们都在这里待了三周了。你们一定有家人吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There was more. The Secretary of State for Education called in England's former counterterror chief from Scotland Yard, a man named Peter Clarke. And the Birmingham City Council appointed its own special investigator. And they scrutinized Park View along with 20-some-odd other schools in Muslim neighborhoods.
还有更多。教育大臣召集了苏格兰场的前反恐主管，一个名叫彼得·克拉克的人。伯明翰市议会也任命了自己的特别调查员。他们审查了公园景观中学以及穆斯林社区的其他20多所学校。
In the middle of the melee, some politicians and journalists were saying that the letter itself was likely a hoax. There was some obvious factual inaccuracies. Yet the government believed it still warranted this action. Honestly, I don't think any authority explained this logic with much clarity at the time.
在混乱中，一些政客和记者说这封信本身很可能是一个恶作剧。确实存在一些明显的与事实不符的地方。然而政府认为它仍然值得采取行动。说实话，我不认为当时的任何权威机构能清晰地解释这一逻辑。
But my understanding of how the thinking went is that, even if the letter itself wasn't an actual communiqué between two real-life conspirators, it could still be pointing at a real problem. Even if it was fiction, the thinking went, the letter could have been fabricated by someone who had legitimate concerns about Muslim extremists scheming and wielding influence in schools. And maybe the letter was their creative way of raising an alarm.
但我对这种想法的理解是，即使信件本身不是两个现实阴谋家之间的真实通讯，它仍然可能指向一个真正的问题。这种想法认为，即使它是虚构的，这封信也可能是由某些对穆斯林极端分子策划并在学校发挥影响力有合法担忧的人所捏造的。也许这封信是他们引起警觉的某种创造性方式。
So rather than look into who wrote the letter and why, instead, the government put out general public calls for information about these schools. And people started coming forward, mostly anonymously, with complaints. Again, investigators found no evidence of radicalization, no evidence of violent extremism, and no plot. What emerged instead was a kind of grab bag of Islam-adjacent allegations.
所以，与其调查是谁写了这封信以及为什么写，政府反而向公众发出了一般性呼吁，要求提供关于这些学校的信息。人们开始站出来，大多是匿名地提出投诉。同样，调查人员没有发现激进化的证据，没有暴力极端主义的证据，也没有阴谋的证据。取而代之的是一种关于伊斯兰的各种指控大杂烩。
Many of the same things authorities had celebrated up to that point, but apparently now were seeing in a different light. Like, these educators weren't merely allowing students to pray. They were pressuring them to pray. They weren't innocently recruiting Brown Muslim staff. They were hiring their buddies who thought the same way as they did, and possibly discriminating against non-Muslim candidates in the process.
许多当局此前一直赞赏的事情，现在显然被以不同的眼光看待了。比如，这些教育工作者不仅仅是允许学生祈祷。他们在强迫他们祈祷。他们并非无辜地招募棕色皮肤的穆斯林员工。他们是在招聘那些和他们想法一致的伙伴，并在过程中可能歧视非穆斯林候选人。
School governors, including Tahir, they weren't holding headteachers to a high standard. They were pressuring them, harassing them, and exercising more power than a governor was supposed to. Investigators also said they'd found instances of intolerance towards LGBTQ people and unequal treatment of women and girls. They said Park View had held assemblies and invited speakers with anti-Western views. And that Tahir and people aligned with him allegedly subscribed to, quote, "An intolerant and politicized form of extreme social conservatism that claims to represent, and ultimately seeks to control, all Muslims."
学校校董，包括塔希尔，他们没有以高标准要求校长。他们在施压、骚扰他们，并行使了超出校董应有范围的权力。调查人员还说，他们发现了对LGBTQ人群不容忍以及对妇女和女孩不平等对待的例子。他们说公园景观中学举办了晨会，邀请了持反西方观点的发言人。塔希尔和与他结盟的人涉嫌信奉“一种不宽容且政治化的极端社会保守主义，声称代表并最终寻求控制所有穆斯林。”
All of this, as the then Secretary of State for Education put it as she presented the findings on the Trojan Horse letter to Parliament, meant that students--
这一切，正如当时的教育大臣在向议会介绍关于“特洛伊木马信”的调查结果时所言，意味着学生们——
Instead of enjoying a broadening and enriching experience in school, young people are having their horizons narrowed and are being denied the opportunity to flourish in a modern, multicultural Britain.
不再是在学校享受广泛且丰富的体验，年轻人正面临视野变窄的情况，并被剥夺了在现代多元文化英国茁壮成长的机会。
It is for this reason, and with a deep sense of injustice and sadness, that today we are announcing our intention to resign our positions at Park View Educational Trust and allow new members to assume responsibility with the--
正是因为这个原因，怀着深深的不公和悲伤，今天我们宣布辞去公园景观教育信托的职位，并让新成员承担责任——
After months of scrutiny, in early July, 2014, Tahir, looking tired and stressed, stood at a lectern outside Park View's gates and resigned. Tahir told us he and the other Park View governors only agreed to do that because the Department for Education promised that the head teacher and other on-the-ground leadership of the school would be kept in place.
经过几个月的审查，2014年7月初，看起来疲惫且紧张的塔希尔站在公园景观中学大门外的演讲台上辞职了。塔希尔告诉我们，他和公园景观中学的其他校董之所以同意这样做，是因为教育部承诺学校的校长和现场领导层将保留原职。
But as soon as school opened in September, all of those people were suspended. All the leadership was basically sacked. Ruthlessly, they went about it destroying their careers, destroying their reputations. And they did that systematically. We had worked for 10, 15 years, really, to build this school. They destroyed it within months.
但9月份学校一开学，所有那些人就被停职了。所有领导层基本上都被解雇了。他们无情地去摧毁他们的职业生涯，摧毁他们的名声。而且他们是系统性地这样做的。我们工作了10年、15年，真的，为了建立这所学校。他们几个月内就摧毁了它。
The government renamed the school. It's no longer Park View. It also notified nearly every teacher and governor you just heard from, Tahir included, that it was bringing proceedings to ban them from education for the rest of their lives.
政府重新命名了学校。它不再是公园景观中学了。它还通知了你刚才听到的几乎每一位教师和校董，包括塔希尔，说正在进行程序禁止他们余生从事教育工作。
In the years since, student achievement has plummeted at the school formerly known as Park View. From more than 70% passing to, in recent years, from the low-40% to mid-50% range.
此后的几年里，前公园景观中学学生成绩一落千丈。从超过70%的通过率下降到近年来40%多到50%多的范围。
So that's the story Tahir told us, that first meeting, in his makeshift tutoring room, that this letter, which was never fully investigated, that described a plot called Operation Trojan Horse, which was never found to have existed, inspired all of this, the ruining of careers and an educational movement, the fear-mongering headlines against Muslims that continue to this day, the government instituting policies that encourage us to spy more brazenly on each other. We'd been talking with Tahir for a couple of hours by this point.
这就是塔希尔第一次见面时在临时辅导室里告诉我们的故事，这封从未被彻底调查过的信，描述了一个从未被发现存在的名为“特洛伊木马行动”的阴谋，却引发了这一切——事业和教育运动的破坏、至今仍在持续的针对穆斯林的煽动性头条、政府制定了鼓励我们更无耻地互相窥探的政策。到这时，我们已经和塔希尔谈了几个小时了。
What time is it? I know you need to leave at some point. I don't want--
现在几点了？我知道你必须在某个时候离开。我不希望——
I mean, I'm-- I have to go to Friday prayer now. So, 1 o'clock, I'm there really.
我是说，我——我现在得去参加周五的祈祷。所以，1点钟，我真的得在那儿。
I understand it's a lot to talk. So if you wanted to--
我理解，要谈的事情很多。所以如果你想——
There's a lot to-- no, no, I don't get tired of talking these things really. I mean, you probably could tell. Obviously, when I talk about that, you know, you begin to relive it, isn't it? And I have to say that it does sadden me, actually, as to what has been lost for the children, for the community, the irreparable damage that has been done for absolutely no reason whatsoever. So, anyway, can I get you guys some tea or something?
要说的很多——不，不，我谈这些事情一点也不觉得累。我是说，你可能看出来了。很明显，当我谈到这些时，你知道，你开始重温这一切，不是吗？我必须说，对于孩子们、对于社区所失去的一切，对于以完全没有任何理由的方式所造成的不可弥补的伤害，我确实感到悲伤。总之，我可以给你们弄点茶什么的吗？
At that event I went to, where we all got redirected to the wedding hall, one of the speakers, a columnist named Peter Oborne, put it well. He said Operation Trojan Horse has become a social fact in Britain. That, even though within weeks that the Trojan Horse started hitting the news, people acknowledged it was probably a hoax, that's never seemed to matter. Whether Muslims in Birmingham were conspiring or not doesn't matter. The intimation that they were has persevered, to the extent that a prime minister's former chief of staff was outraged that some people in the community center would dare to say otherwise.
在那场我们都被改道到婚礼大厅参加的活动上，其中一位发言人、专栏作家彼得·奥伯恩说得很对。他说，“特洛伊木马行动”已经成为英国的一个“社会事实”。即使在“特洛伊木马”开始上新闻后的几周内，人们承认它可能是一个骗局，这似乎从来都不重要。伯明翰的穆斯林是否在密谋并不重要。那种暗示他们已经在密谋的观点已经根深蒂固，以至于首相的前幕僚长竟然对社区中心有人敢说不感到愤怒。
But we don't need to settle for a social fact because there are actual facts. Why, up to this point, has no one cared about who wrote this letter and where this letter came from?
但我们不需要满足于一个“社会事实”，因为有事实。为什么到目前为止，没人关心是谁写了这封信，这封信从哪里来？
Well, that's my question.
嗯，那是我的问题。
(LAUGHING) That's my question.
[笑声] 那也是我的问题。
This is what I've been arguing. This is why I went to the police to see what they could do. This is what I wrote in my letter to the Birmingham City Council, that you need to get to the bottom of who wrote the letter. This is what I wrote to the Department of Education as well. You need to get to the bottom of the letter, who wrote the letter. Because that will then unravel why the letter was written. You see? So this is what I have been arguing.
这就是我一直在争论的。这就是我为什么去警察局看看他们能做什么的原因。这就是我在写给伯明翰市议会的信中写的，你需要查清是谁写了这封信。这也是我写给教育部的原因。你需要查清这封信的底细，是谁写的这封信。因为那才会揭开为什么写这封信的原因。你明白吗？这就是我一直争论的。
But Department of Education is not interested. The police are not interested. The Birmingham City Council is not interested in answering that question.
但教育部不感兴趣。警察不感兴趣。伯明翰市议会不感兴趣回答这个问题。
Why?
为什么？
Because they have used this letter. And on this hoax they have built so much policy. Do you think now they want to launch an investigation into the letter to have it proven that it was written for completely different reasons? Yeah? How would that make them look like? A bunch of monkeys.
因为他们利用了这封信。而在这个骗局之上，他们建立了如此多的政策。你以为现在他们想对这封信发起调查来证明它是因为完全不同的原因写的吗？是吗？那会让他们看起来像什么？一群猴子。
As I've been saying, if you could just find out who wrote that letter and why, that's the only thing that might change Britain's understanding of Operation Trojan Horse.
正如我一直说的，如果你能找出是谁写的那封信以及为什么写，那是唯一可能改变英国对“特洛伊木马行动”理解的事情。
But whoever wrote the letter, they knew me, I think. And I like to think that I know them too.
但不管是谁写的这封信，我想他们了解我。而且我想我大概也了解他们。
Does that mean you think--
那意味着你认为——
I have a strong hunch as to who wrote the letter. I strongly believe that I know who wrote the letter. And I strongly believe that I know the why the letter was written as well.
我有一个强烈的预感，是谁写了这封信。我强烈地相信我知道是谁写了这封信。而且我也强烈地相信我知道写这封信的原因。
So you think you know the who and the motive.
所以你认为你知道“谁”和“动机”。
Yes.
是的。
That's next on The Trojan Horse Affair.
下期《特洛伊木马事件》见。
So that is part 1 of The Trojan Horse Affair. You can listen to all eight installments right now, wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是《特洛伊木马事件》的第一部分。你现在可以在任何收听播客的地方听到全部八集。
[MUSIC - "FROGGY" BY JAYKAE AND DAPZ ON THE MAP]
[音乐 - Jaykae和Dapz on the Map的《Froggy》]
The Trojan Horse Affair is produced by Brian Reed and Hamza Syed, with Rebecca Laks. It's edited by Sarah Koenig with help from Julie Snyder, Neil Drumming, and me. Contributing editor is Ayesha Manazir Siddiqi. Fact checkers, Marika Cronnolly and Ben Phelan. The episode was mixed by Steven Jackson. Audio was provided by NBC, Getty Images. Bim Adewunmi, and Mike Comite help put their show into an episode of our show.
《特洛伊木马事件》由布莱恩·里德和哈姆扎·赛义德制作，丽贝卡·拉克斯协助。由莎拉·凯尼格编辑，朱莉·斯奈德、尼尔·德拉明和我提供了帮助。特约编辑是阿耶莎·马纳兹尔·西迪基。事实核查员：玛丽卡·克罗诺利和本·费伦。本集由史蒂文·杰克逊混音。音频素材由NBC和盖蒂图片社提供。比姆·阿德温米和迈克·科米特帮助将此节目放入了我们节目的某一集中。
Special thanks today to Richard Danbury, Kimberly Henderson, The Barclay Agency, Kenneth Pomeranz, Greg Clark, and John Holmwood.
今天特别感谢理查德·丹伯里、金伯利·亨德森、巴克莱经纪公司、肯尼斯·波梅兰茨、格雷格·克拉克和约翰·霍姆伍德。
The Trojan Horse Affair is made by Serial Productions and The New York Times. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
《特洛伊木马事件》由Serial Productions和《纽约时报》制作。我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX送达公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。
Sure, you always love Shakespeare, the Beatles, the BBC, Harry Potter. But it was Fleabag that put him over the top.
当然，你总是喜欢莎士比亚、披头士、BBC、哈利·波特。但正是《伦敦生活》让他脱颖而出。
So, from that point onwards, I've started calling myself British. I was just like, well, I'm British. I own this country.
所以从那时起，我就开始称自己为英国人。我就觉得，好吧，我是英国人。我拥有这个国家。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的故事中。
[MUSIC - "FROGGY" BY JAYKAE AND DAPZ ON THE MAP]
[音乐 - Jaykae和Dapz on the Map的《Froggy》]
(SINGING) We know, we know. We know, we know.
（演唱）我们知道，我们知道。我们知道，我们知道。